[Music]
several American towns claim to be the
birthplace of the Sunday Sunday's first
appeared in the 1880s when the sale of
ice-cream sodas was banned on Sundays
instead soda fountain operators poured
soda syrup on ice cream added toppings
and called this new treat to Sunday
today ice cream sundaes come pre-made
and frozen in individual servings
there's no need to wait this decadent
dessert can be served up in an instant
at the sundae factory production starts
with something called the white base mix
it's a pasteurized blend of fresh cream
milk and a variety of sweeteners a
worker adds a blend of yellow coloring
to the white base mix and this takes it
from bright white to an off-white a
generous helping of pure vanilla extract
lends a distinctive flavor and adds
extra color to the cream base after a
final stir the mix is ready for a
freezing process during which air will
be added to turn the mix into soft ice
cream it's time to cue the containers
two at a time individual sized sundae
cups move forward on the production line
they meet up with the ice cream
dispenser
it automatically pumps precise amounts
of the soft vanilla ice cream into the
cups
[Music]
it fills the cups to the 3/4 mark
leaving plenty of room for toppings it's
now time to prepare the next layer of
deliciousness the chocolate fudge sauce
a worker makes his skim milk and
sweeteners to a frothy consistency and
then adds several large bags of dark
rich cocoa the mixer paddle agitates the
ingredients to distribute the cocoa
evenly throughout the chocolate fudge is
pumped into a plastic tote to cool
overnight during cooling the sauce
thickens up substantially
it's now a rich chocolate fudge syrup
velvety smooth the chocolate syrup flows
out of the tote and into a big tank from
their nozzles dispense the chocolate
fudge syrup onto the vanilla ice cream
in the cups
[Music]
next a worker pours a liquid topping
blend into a high-speed mixer system
that beats it to a whipped consistency
nozzles deposit the whipped topping onto
the syrup covered ice cream now it's
time to add some chocolate crunch to the
smooth sweet sundae the system sprinkles
semi-sweet chocolate chunks onto the
whipped topping
it's the final touch these single
serving chocolate sundaes have been
prepared almost entirely by machines
a conveyor now sends them through an icy
blast of air for a quick freeze exiting
the freezer the frozen sundaes travel
forward shielded by overhead guards for
food safety reasons the sundaes funnel
into a single-file Lane this positions
them to receive lids
the lids slide down a chute and land on
top of the ice cream sundae cups rollers
press the lids down on the rims a
revolving apparatus deposits plastic
collars around the lids moving forward
the machinery sorts the sundae cups and
rows of two this allows a robot with
suctioning arms to pick up six at a time
and pack them into a cardboard box the
boxes travel under and over packing tape
to seal the tops and bottoms incredibly
this factory produces 1440 ice cream
sundae cups every 15 minutes and it's
all thanks to the magic of mechanization
this company also produces tubs of
flavored ice cream so there are many
mouth-watering choices to be made at
dessert time
[Music]